hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well near the end of part two of his
prolog to any future metaphysics
Emmanuel Kant is going to talk not just
about law of nature as he has been
through this entire section but about a
distinction between what we can call
Universal or pure laws of nature and
then empirical laws of nature both of
which natural science is concerned with
and you could say is made out of and how
do we get there well he begins in part
36 asking this question how is n natur
itself possible and he says that this
question uh properly contains two
distinct questions which are
interrelated to each other so both of
these have meanings or senses but doong
right there's a material sense and a
formal sense and here Kant is you know
using some sort of
oldfashioned language that was quite
established in his time particularly in
Scholastic philosophy and in early
modern philosophy as well so the
material
sense you could think about it in terms
of form and content as well the material
sense he says how is nature possible in
general in this sense that is according
to intuition onong as the
totality of appearances he's going to
use this term totality
uh in both of them and now we get a
little bit more specific how our space
time and that which fills both the
object of sensation possible in general
now some of this we've already talked
about in previous sections and he says
well the answer is by means of the
Constitution the be bishopan height
right how something is made how
something has been created or gen
generated the constitution of
sensibility um Zite right so he says
according to which it is in its special
way the
sensibility affected by objects which
are in themselves unknown to it the
things in themselves the
numina and totally distinct from those
appearances those
iroman and so he says you know I've
talked about this in the critique uh we
don't need to go into this any further
what we're really more concerned with
here is the formal sense and in what is
the asking about here how is nature
possible in this sense as the
totality of the
rules under which all appearances must
come in order to be thought as connected
in an experience so you know we get from
sensibility and intuition
through it we get uh appearances and
then what do we do with those we bring
them under rules and we do so without
even consciously thinking about it this
is the way that we apprehend a world
outside this is the way we have
experience in the first place so I said
well the answer to this is It's only
possible by means of the Constitution
again bashen height of our understanding
so we've got these two different
faculties which are intimately connected
sensibility which is lower in some
respect the understanding Which is
higher and More
determinative in some respects and each
of them is handling you could say a
different set of tasks and so he says um
all those representations of sensibility
are referred to a
Consciousness and by which the PE way in
which we think that is by rules we think
using logical determinations connecting
things together so he says hence also
experience is possible but also must be
clearly distinguished from insight into
the objects in itself so we're we're you
know sticking to the world of possible
experience he goes on and he says that
you know when it comes to these laws of
nature um there are many which we can
only know by means of experience so by
actually looking at things experiencing
things measuring things you know so this
is indeed what a lot of Natural Science
does consist in you know so Kant for
example doesn't really talk about
chemistry here he talks about physics
and about geometry but he could talk
about chemistry and say well you
actually do have to perform experiments
if you want to know something about how
certain things interact with each other
so experience is in indeed
important but we don't learn about all
of the laws of nature through experience
through
experimentation through correlating
these things there are some laws and
these are the by far the mo most
important ones that precede experience
so he says we can't discover uh the
Conformity to law and the connection of
appearances nature in general by any
experience why because experience itself
requires that we have laws which are a
priori at the very basis of its
possibility the possibility of
experience so U we've already seen this
in the discussion of the judgments of
perception and the judgments of
experience what what differentiates them
well in the um judgments of experience
experience we are bringing pure ideas of
the understanding to bear in there so
we're adding something in you could
say so this is what gets us to Pure or
universal laws of nature which he is
going to say are the so here here we go
the possibility of experience in general
is therefore at the same time the
universal law of Nature and the
principles of experience are the very
laws of nature why because we only know
nature as the totality of appearances
representations in us so we can only
derive the law of their connection from
the principles of their Connection in us
in our Consciousness this is the very
possibility of having experience and
Kant is going to call these Universal or
pure laws of nature the highest
legislation and he's going to say that
this highest
legislation
lies in ourselves and where does it lie
in ourselves well primarily in
sensibility and the understanding so
he's going to go on and say that um here
we go we must not seek the universal
laws of nature in nature by means of
experience we have must seek nature as
to its Universal conformity to law in
the conditions of the possibility of
experience which lie in notice he says
two things our sensibility and our
understanding we need both of these in
order to be able to derive these
Universal or pure laws of nature and he
goes on a little bit later and he's
going to say that the understanding does
not derive laws from uh nature right but
rather prescribes them to Nature so what
our understanding is doing this is not
exactly what Kant says but if we want to
sort of wrap our heads around it in
contemporary language our understanding
is
continually projecting onto whatever it
is that we could
experience all this structure this order
these lawlike
connections between things it's doing it
all the time that's why we're able to
have experience in the first place which
then we can derive some you know other
laws of nature from what he calls the
empirical experiential laws of nature
and he tells us that these presupposed
for alen uh you know they they are um
setting out in advance particular bizra
perceptions V name right perception is
not yet the same thing as experience for
Emmanuel Kant we've seen the Judgment of
perception Judgment of experience two
different things right so empirical laws
of nature in order to have those we
actually have to do observation
experientially within the world and then
we can you know come up with things but
the very possibility of doing that is
based on having Universal or pure laws
of nature so both of these are important
for Natural Science and both of them are
heavily involved in what we're doing now
he's going to give us some interesting
examples but before we look at the
examples we should think about what is
this what are these examples supposed to
demonstrate or prove or at least
illustrate to us and Kant is going to
tell us after providing them he says
here is nature resting on law laws which
the understanding
cognizes a priori chiefly from Universal
principles of the determination of space
and he says do the laws of nature lie in
space does the understanding learn them
by merely endeavoring to find out the
enormous wealth of meaning that lies in
space no it's the other way around he
says uh the mere Universal form of
intuition called space is the substratum
of intuitions determinable to particular
objects they exist in space and in it of
course the condition of the possibility
and of the variety of these intuitions
lies but very important but here the
unity of the objects is determined
entirely by the understanding and
according to conditions which lie in its
own nature the the nature of the
understanding thus the understanding is
the origin of the Universal order of
nature right so this is really uh an
important pivotal Point here so what are
the examples that he provides he talks
about the properties of a circle so we
draw a circle we uh have some chords
which are lines that are intersecting
each other and the circle and they are
always divided so the rectangle
constructed with the segments of the one
is equal to that constructed with the
segments of the other doing basic
geometry stuff that you may have done in
your high school geometry class or you
could get out of a textbook K says all
right what's what's important about this
does this law the law about these being
you know equal to each other lie in the
circle in the thing itself that we're
observing or does it lie in the
understanding he says does the figure
independently of the understanding
contain in itself the ground of the law
or does the understanding having
constructed according to its Concepts
what are they the equality of the radi
the figure itself introduce into it this
law of the courts and K says it's the
latter the understanding is is providing
you with the laws in this case right he
says if we enlarge this concept to look
at other geometric figures under common
laws and consider the circle as a conic
section so a a cone a three-dimensional
rather than two-dimensional object
object he says we find that the chords
which intersect within the circle
ellipse Parabola always intersect so
that the rectangles of their segments
are not equal looks like we have a
different law here but always bear a
constant ratio to each other right so
when we're doing geometry something that
we discussed in the previous section
right um we see that the understanding
is prescribing the rules what about
another thing that seems to be empirical
Universal attraction of matter to each
other mutual attraction as well or as we
call it gravity or gravitation right
says if we proceed to the fundamental
doctrines of physical
astronomy um we find that there's a
physical law of reciprocal
attraction the rule of which is that it
decreases inversely as the square of the
distance from each attracting points so
we've got a MTH mathematical or
mathemati connection which we can
observe in
nature we can do that because the
understanding is actually according to
Kant prescribing the very order the
structure The Rules of Nature by means
of the universal pure laws of nature to
what it is that we are observing that's
so that's what these examples are
supposed to lead us toward so we've got
this distinction now between pure and
empirical laws of nature they're both
part of Natural Science but one is far
more important one is the ground for the
other and it comes from the Constitution
the way things are set up the way things
if we want to be very literal about aaen
height the way things are made with
these two faculties of sensibility and
the much more important one the
understanding